beyoncé's mile high fashion cost her a
boatload Harry Styles and James Corden
share a smooch plus the Royals visit the
last Jedi London premiere a friend's
Denny here now if you watch me on the
daily then you know I stand for Beyonce
and as proud as I am to be in the
Beehive I try not to bombard you with
everything Beyonce but I can't ignore
this this is how the Carters travel in
style
Beyonce shared this pic on a plane with
jay-z J rocking the all-white lookin
baller and Beyonce serving us looks get
this her ensemble it costs nearly
$15,000 and that doesn't even include
the jewelry folks the sparkly sailor on
boots alone ten grand
these bags nearly $1,500 and a t-shirt a
cool 500 and that white belt giving a
Wonder Woman a run for her money that
cost about $400 all I'm saying is this
is how you Slade outfit when you're the
queen of everything meanwhile queen
bee's duet on Ed Sheeran's perfect has
officially earned the singer her first
number-one single since single ladies
now for someone who has not dropped her
own music this year beyonce stock is
still rising as the year ends and as I
reported last week we know beyonce is
hard at work for her next gig headlining
next year's Coachella best of all the
choreographer jaquail night told me that
performance is going to be a
game-changer but as if we had any doubt
am i right nothing might Beyonce gushing
though because I also can't get over
this clip from last night's carpool
karaoke James Corden shared a special
holiday mashup of the popular segment
and proved that when you have Harry
Styles in your car you don't need
mistletoe to make a move
happy Christmas
[Music]
happy Christmas house
[Music]
I saw according kissing every style whoa
a good deep hurt oh I live for that clip
oh Happy Holidays to me
all right meanwhile there was no funny
business at Star Wars in the last Jedi
premiere in London but they did get the
Royal Treatment both Prince William and
Prince Harry hit the carpet at Royal
Albert Hall on Tuesday looking oh so
dapper and not only did they meet up
with their stormtrooper friends but they
were also greeted by none other than
bb-8 now both are rumored to have cameos
in the latest Star Wars films John
boyega himself said the brothers hopped
in front of the cameras dressed as
stormtroopers during a visit to the film
set at Pinewood Studios in April 2016
clearly they had a bit of fun while they
were there meanwhile Daisy Ridley played
it a bit more coy about their cameos
though she did reveal which of the two
would make a better stormtrooper I
cannot comment or whether the Princess
Alice don't know it would make a better
one by the way it's so exciting they're
coming to the European premiere how
excited are you already so I'm like yeah
yeah just to catch up how you've been
you got engaged nice now is that great
well we'll just have to keep an eye out
for the Royal Bros when Star Wars the
last Jedi hits theatres up this weekend
I'm going Thursday I cannot wait in the
meantime get excited because today is
the digital release of one of my
favorite films this year the lego
ninjago movie and now one of them i give
us a lego thumbs up if you'll be
watching and don't worry it will also be
available on blu-ray December 19 just in
time to gift it to the ninja and your
life alright guys that's it for today
thanks for watching we are cooking up
some fun end-of-the-year stuff for you
guys so keep a lot to the daily
denne for more and I'll see you guys
tomorrow